hello there guys so the actress who
plays ahsoka vasari dawson has revealed
that an episode of the upcoming star
wars disney plush show ahsoka has had an
entire episode edited together and dave
filoni said watching the episode was a
religious experience so this is the
first time we've heard anything
regarding an episode for the upcoming
ahsoka show and dave cullen of religious
experience is just high praise and
really excited to hear obviously dave
fallon would be involved in this project
in some way but just hearing him saying
it's like a religious experience just
makes me want to speculate because there
was a rumor of hayden christensen being
signed on to play in the series does
that mean we're finally going to get a
scene of force ghost anakin potentially
an encounter between ahsoka and anakin
because to me watching that whole
interaction would be quite a religious
experience it would just bring so many
things full circle and just be
incredibly incredibly emotional now to
do with the room of hayden christensen
signing on to be in this series the only
other role i can see him play is darth
vader in the flashback sequence so
possibly even a live-action recreation
of the jewel between ahsoka and vader
anyway let me know what you guys think
in the comment section below and if you
did enjoy this video please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching